there was big Obamacare news this week
on the positive side signups have
surpassed 8 million people but
unfortunately on Thursday it turned out
that one state in particular is lagging
behind Oregon has officially shut down
its online health care exchange after
weeks are trying to fix its bulky
glitchy system Oregon residents will now
use the federal healthcare.gov site
signup for medical insurance all toll
taxpayers have coughed up a whopping 248
million for a website that still doesn't
work wait wait wait okay so let's let's
break all of that down
Oregon spent a quarter of a billion
dollars and its website designed to sign
people up in one sitting
did that for exactly nobody and they're
now handing the keys over to
healthcare.gov that has got to be a
bitter pill to swallow for the people of
Oregon or it would be if they could get
the pill which they can't the best
shitty website is broken now to be fair
to be fair to be fair to Oregon not all
of that money was spent on the website
itself 3 million of it was spent on
violently adorable adverts like this
to care for each one every daughter and
son live we get it Oregon you people
live in a cartoon your mountains are
breathtaking your coffee is fair trade
and everywhere you go you hear the sound
of ukuleles you've made your
point but here's the thing this is all
very charming until you waste tens of
millions of dollars of taxpayer money on
a website that doesn't work luckily we
here have prepared something to convey
that message to you in a way that I
think you'll be able to understand like
Gardens in Portland your site doesn't
work that 404 air
you blew on
when you break your leg drive
stupid Oregon
your passion for cuteness might kill
your home
you